this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody welcome once
again to the Sun set Safari yeah down in
Juma in the South Africa where we sit
with a few lions lying down here just on
the side of the road my name is Steven
I'm joined by Sebastian ROM be on camera
and we are very excited to be out on
this very cool and blustery afternoon
it's about 22 degrees Celsius about 63
degrees Fahrenheit and well we found
them this morning and we have managed to
find them again
so that guy there is the Evoque a male
known as snarly or Mohawk either one
he's got a very distinctive sort of
mohawk to him he's got a very beaten up
face since last I saw him we'll
hopefully get another look at him and he
is with also amber eyes I think I'm not
sure at the moment which one is our
buyers and which one is the purple eye
but amber eyes is one of those two and
purple eye is the other one they're both
pretty old lionesses DUP and apparently
though we didn't see it this morning but
apparently there was at least one mating
session with the server camille and
amber eyes which is quite exciting
Tristan and I was chatting it about it
before and wouldn't it be wonderful if
the uncle homers gave birth to a number
of cabs just like the baby boom of the
Mara that is taking place right now to
go in conjunction with our hyena den the
Juma clan
baby boom as well vocals are
well-established now they've been here
since about February March last year
coming in and out and since about May or
so they haven't really been challenged
by anyone that we know about down here
in Juma what goes on up in the northern
areas of before suck up into money laity
to the north of us and very hard to say
but now that they are looking off these
females maybe it will be time for some
Cubs to follow anyway I'm not the only
one out the south
Charlotte has headed a little bit
further west for me she's going to see
if she can find the other group of from
this morning well I'm so glad you've
come over to me to see what I'm doing
because I have just arrived at a
wonderful sighting
let's see surprise more lions how
exciting is that
sorry guys I didn't even get to
introduce myself I got excited here at
the lion sighting but I'm sure she'll
and I've got Craig on camera and we're
really excited to be here with these
lions now if you look closely you'll see
there's two females and one male here
the male is an extreme right you can see
sort of the main study so apparently
they've made it really really soon a
couple minutes ago
so it might be a few more minutes till
they made again and until then they will
probably be sitting around like this and
sitting around in sort of the shade it's
a bit cooler now and then I'll get up do
a bit of grooming and then they will
meet again
I'd love to get a really good look at
them
study so now these two
mrs. I know is that it you are you are
saying that RDR you're asking are these
more think of Miss I was just about to
tell you guys these this these both of
these females are in fact in kokoomus
and the one male there is the Avoca male
now you know these are our resident
prides or our resident pride in humans
and the Evoque of males is the male
coalition that's formed with the
incomers so they will often be mating
together they sort of owner the humans
in a way if that makes sense but this
group of this pride of females belongs
to the Avoca males now I'd like to know
which one it is if he lifts his lovely
head up you'll be able to see but from
what I understand these two lionesses on
the ground share is ridge nose and one
of the sub-adult lionesses
both very tired I suppose exhausted from
the day's mating but they found
themselves a nice patch but of @m Bertie
Grove and some nice grass she lay down
in
well these lines will be here for a
while which means so will I because it's
only a matter of time until they get up
and start to mate which would be really
awesome I love to see that I've always
really liked when I see mating animals
it's just such a special thing anyway
David up in the Maasai Mara seems to be
battling a bit of a storm and he's
driving around so let's go to him to say
hello jumbo everyone and welcome to
their very rainy mara triangle I'm sure
nothing looks familiar here but this
tells you this has a long range the long
rains have started but we are going to
survive my name is David and uncover
with me is a Manu yesterday we were in
the mid of a very big storm now the
signs are silver that the rains will
continue but nothing worried we are off
Palestine
mum have a very special window who he
was just maybe slightly give you a
snippet of what is outside there this is
the inside we just have an idea of how
things look out there and I'm sure you
can hear it hitting our rain cover the
ring
can you hear the rain ladies and
gentlemen can you see that I'm sure you
can see a huge wall of rain yes and I'm
sure I'm in the final control is direct
this show and and I'm sure you'd like to
know what transpired yesterday and we
are all very good we survived it so what
you did very quickly we had to power
down and brought all the flaps down open
things will get better and we waited for
about 45 minutes one hour and rain got
bigger and bigger and we made a quick
decision back in the camp have a cup of
tea have a cup of coffee and look what
they will bring but I'm very hopeful
things will not be bad and it's steep
having started Lions trishal of lions
that's a good sign lots of lions in
Douma hopefully we are going to get our
STPs which are going to look for and
definitely Steve and Trish alla have
already Requested you for comments and
questions as usual
hashtag safari live on twitter well as
much as it's raining is a bit warm here
is 25 degrees celsius and 77 degrees
Fahrenheit which me works very well so
third man who yesterday were not really
caught off guard but today we are more
prepared than yesterday or what you see
there is nothing but rain now the long
range will always touch the month of
March going all the way to June but this
time they have started in the month of
April
as you shortly didn't gentlemen I'm sure
you always do my plan and get into the
sausage republic and ice I do that
within your back to Vova or with his new
comers I guess
thanks Gigi
try and stay dry this evening don't get
washed off the road like you did
yesterday here we go that's am bars on
the left everybody that's purple I in
the middle and that is snidely the
Mohawk two vocal mail on the right they
are thoroughly enjoying lying our chair
honor the soft grass they haven't done
much apart from a rollover slightly so
maybe we'll get to see a mating session
between them but one mating session for
the whole day because we had Ollie who
came out just to just to keep an eye on
the Lions today just to make sure that
they didn't leave and well you only saw
them mate once so it's very interesting
because normally when they're mating
pair are busy you can almost time it in
the beginning it's seven eight minutes
and then slows down to every 15 minutes
and then towards the end of it it starts
becoming over twenty five thirty minutes
and once in a day well I remember excuse
me
being with AM buyers and one of the
Birmingham boys up at before suck damn
probably about this time actually last
year I can't remember exactly maybe but
earlier and the entire time we spent
with her they're only mates at once she
was a very grumpy lady almost as if she
is in East respeto
her mood is not quite there which is
always quite interesting
but right now it seems like lions are
doing exactly what they do best hello
Saul yes most certainly Lions will
essentially lose their pride during sort
of the mating sort of story during the
situation and the female will or the
male will follow the female invariably
the pride moves away or they could stay
in a similar sort of area depending on
food if they've gone hunting or whatever
it might be and after two three days
four days maybe the female and the male
both of them will come to sort of a a
Hunger sort of stalemate and they'll
split apart to go and eat and then
you'll often find that female rejoining
the pride and trying her level best to
lose sort of the attention of the male
who has been trying to follow her the
entire time so that is the ideal
situation but we saw up in the Maasai
Mara their kinky tail seemed to be in
sort of a mating relationship before
almost three weeks and that was very
interesting to see I've never seen
anything quite like that before
but then everybody Lions don't read the
books so but they don't need to return
to the pride they can be quite
successful hunting on their own but they
are much more successful with their
sisters and family in tow we've seen
amber eyes last year as well when she
had Cubs over in the West she would
stash the Cubs not that we ever saw them
with that information from the guides in
the West and then she'd come charging
all the way to the other side of June I
could actually track her from the West
come in to find the pride so as to get
some food and then she'd spend a few
days before going back unfortunately
each time that happened she had some
failures with regards to maybe that Den
side she chose not really sure I heard
some stories that hyenas had gotten to
one of the litters but anyway open that
is a very sad state of affairs but amber
eyes as yet as far as we are aware to
successfully reel any youngsters
okay well everybody has you know and
there's also another person up this
afternoon or maybe we didn't know that
but Tristan has found some tracks of
Columba and he would really like to find
us let's go and see how he's getting on
indeed Alice Fleur I don't have any
tawny colored cats
I'm the unlucky one Hart this afternoon
but that's fine because that allows me
to go looking for the spotted ones which
we all know I prefer anyway as Steve
mentioned my name is Tristan on camera
but since a this afternoon and we are
going to be looking for spotty cats I'm
gonna try and see if we can find if
there's tracks for lions here which I
suspect must be the same ones that
Steven Trishula
have seen I don't know I want to ask
them just not just what are the tracks
now but I'm pretty sure these lines come
up and I think they must meet up with
those ones that Steve and Shoshanna have
but we also found tracks for a lipid
looks like four claw Lamba coming from a
little block that she was last seen
mister Charla which tends to suggest
that maybe she had a kill in there the
last couple days and she's now come out
and so she looks as though she's hitting
kind of southwards
so I want to just check treehouse Dam
and twin dams in case she's gone for
water I drove past some impalas just
before I spotted the tracks and they
looked seriously jumpy they were not in
any way relaxed they were kind of
steering in different directions and
sort of as the car came past they were
kind of bolt upright so I don't know if
they maybe saw her during the course of
the day except that the problem is is
that the trucks have been driven over by
a vehicle this morning
there's definitely Lion tracks here so I
don't know if anyone didn't drive yo
what the story is but they come up from
here the sticks pride is also around so
it could very well be some of them they
were seen yesterday on Torchwood moving
a baths they back from their little
joints into the West so you know kind of
pay attention for them to they also
could just appear out of nowhere given
how mobile they've been of enlace so
lots of things to kind of follow up on
down in the South here all Christians
move up in the north hopefully we'll
have some sort of luck with some of
these animals and we'll be able to find
what we're looking for it's not great
we're therefore kind of wards a whole
Patrol it's kind of overcast there's a
bit of a wind that's blowing fairly
chilly it's not really the best kind of
weather to Drive cats to go and drink
but you never know maybe we get lucky
and we'll find something Linda I suspect
that you might be right there's a lot of
potential this evening for a very nice
TV show we've obviously got the two sets
of lions hopefully we're gonna get
roaring from them there's the hyena den
that might be active a little bit later
which if the other two are busy with
I'll head to there and then there's
always a potential as we know of a
spotty cats in this area as well as a
multitude of other animals so you know
there's lots going on and hopefully
we'll be able to get lucky with
something from outsiders where's Steven
trishula are most definitely already
lucky at this stage okay so nothing at
tryouts damn which is not really that
surprising as I was saying I'm just
checking the water points in case
climber came or four kills she might
have gone for water you can just be
lounging about so it's worth just
checking around good as we gonna head
off we're gonna go and check on them so
we're gonna go scratch around and see
what we can find in the meantime and
send you back across the Steve who's
sitting with his lions and hopefully you
know and they'll be busy during the
course of this afternoon
well my liens have moved just slightly
and I can see that one of the females
has rolled over and the other one has
her head caught until he that one
females foot very sweet and you find
that bonding social bonding and touching
and beams actual physical contact with
each other it's such an important thing
for lions and you'll find them often
doing it in fact apparently it's it's
the same for all mammals and there
there's something called a bliss
molecule or serotonin that sort of gets
released and that those pleasure centers
in our brain they they get activated are
they happy when when we're in contact
with people so I said that's the same
for lots of mammals so it applies the
same sort of to us as well in general
people feel some sort of happiness
something gets rewarded in the head when
they bond with others and it's the same
here and when you an inner pride
together and you're constantly with this
group that you're going to hunt together
live together help each other survive
you can imagine how important that is
twitch twitch I wonder what they're
dreaming about Buffalo's definitely
I look at him and he's dark mane
aha Luna a really interesting question
you'd like to know how I can tell or we
can tell when a sub-adult lioness
actually becomes an adult
well lions are fully grown at about
three to four years old and usually in
terms of aging to be or being able to
just by sight look at her apart from
actually knowing their date of birth or
something like that you would notice
that as the years go on the nose of the
lioness which is probably very pink when
they're sub-adult so it is quite pink
when they're sub-adults
gets darker that's one of the things
that is quite obvious you also notice
even stature size that sort of thing but
I find it most the most obvious thing to
me is that a lot of the time before they
are fully grown adults or they sort of
reach their peak which is about seven
years old you'll find that their face
still looks quite young if that makes
sense if these two just look at us then
I could show you what I mean but you'll
find that they they do look still look a
bit cub like that usually goes away by
the time they're about 2 or 3 I find but
then after that it's there you're pretty
much looking at at an adult once it's
capable but like I said they're fully
grown and they reach a maximum size at
around 7 years old so when these two
look at us we'll be able to do a nice
comparison especially looking at their
faces I always find looking at their
face is quite helpful
fee tonight it always amuses me how they
sit and relax and how it seems that no
matter how much I speak around them or
the vehicle coming in they might just
lift up their head once look at me and
that's about it
there's nothing seems to bother them
seems like everyone's lions are not
bothered well they will be bought
bothered very soon when it becomes a
little bit darker and they become active
and we'll we'll be right here when that
does happen so Steve's lions are also
very very lazy so let's go to him
and see if they'll decide to move for
you well stand by everybody you might
get to see an ear flick that's all
that's happening at the moment this male
did sit up for a moment and that's the
mohawk that gives him away because his
face is covered in you and fresh scars
that I haven't seen last Harper saw him
he didn't have as many so we don't
really know what goes on under the cover
of darkness
I remember developing an ID kids for a
pride of lions and the Kruger years ago
there were nine sub adult males and as
Trish says it's just the facial features
change so regularly specially males and
I had put together 90 kits and there are
some very very sort of prevalent scars
that made it quite easy to identify a
few and then a week later another one
looked the same and it's just the scars
on the face make it very very tricky
especially with there's 9 9 young males
all looking similar each week you'd have
to change the photographs females that
they do change but not as much as the
males they're not as physical
hello foul enough amber eyes as Cubs
would have amber eyes well essentially I
color many other traits that someone
will some organism wolf sort of carrion
is normally derived from the parent but
it all depends on how it really
transfers you know depends I suppose
also on what dad and his eyes look like
I mean if dad's got some light-colored
eyes
maybe his genes are but stronger than
hers in in from the chromosome level
they're really hard to say one thing
that I've definitely noticed with lions
is how they do definitely inherit their
fathers mane I've seen that before
where I was talking about those eight
young males that was clearly by the
identification features at least a two
of the dominant males in the area with
the father's you can actually sort of
link the main development and to how
they were looking okay I think that's
purple I said amber eyes if you got his
purple like there we go look at those
teeth it's given us a yawn everybody you
know what this normally means don't you
and we're gonna count down from ten nine
eight
seven six five four that looks like
they're gonna do some grooming but the
afternoon is quite cool they're not in
any shade whatsoever so the Sun has
clearly done an issue for them so
there's a very good chance we might see
these animals up earlier than normal and
with um if you look at the mail on the
right there is Bailey is empty so
whether he's interested in food or more
like amber eyes it's hard to say but
definitely the purple eye darkness was
hunting this morning in the spend time
with her early and she definitely was
excited to try to catch something hello
Rob well I didn't see him but apparently
there were tracks of a male line heading
from north where we are now all the way
to the east and on our eastern boundary
with tortured a road called cheetah cut
line apparently the male lion was found
on that cut line this morning by one of
the cheetah Plains vehicles see her left
canine is wearing down a little bit she
was born in 2012 and she injured her eye
in about April 2017
probably from her either from a claw
while feeding maybe she got one of those
bad abscesses in the eye or maybe she
got kicked by something as she was
trying to eat I suppose you can't blame
an animal that kicking a lion in the
face can you it's about to get mauled to
the ground and ripped apart okay so what
are you gonna do now
show us your catch stretch stretch
[Music]
it's incredible the male line is mating
with two different lions I found that
incredible I've never heard of that
before
when male lion a little menage on [ __ ]
fur you heard of that before said will
you speak French of course you've heard
the term before but have you ever heard
of an airline being with with two
females that is a first for me
but then amber eyes mating with two
brothers and tag-teaming I found
incredible she made it for three weeks
and Bazar no kazars there and she
changed up honestly it took me a bit of
effort to understand who she was mating
with but Nikki Austin our producer knows
lions are very very well and that was
definitely him mating with purple eye
and he mated with amber eyes earlier
today so everybody I really don't know
what to say it's something very new for
me seeing a male lion mating with one
and then if you're gonna mate with the
second one then we're definitely gonna
see it ourselves Louie
purring I suppose you could say it is
purring I mean they are just very big
[ __ ] cats and essentially that noise
that you hear is one of the
communication signals that Lions use
there's a warning involved there's all
sorts of of sort of behavior being sort
of shown when they call like it if
you're walking on foot and you don't see
a lion that battle is pretty much what
you hear long before you see them if
you're listening and when they mate
that's what you see when they feed you
also have that so it's basically a
communication
close-quarters communication between
lions that probably indicates all sorts
of things excitement over feeding
there's definitely excitement there's
also dominance between it because a big
animal it's gonna
make more noise more resonance so for
example a cab if it he has a male lion
make that noise will invariably go okay
I've overstepped some sporm of boundary
leopards do a similar sort of sound of
just not as loud but indeed it's
definitely got something to do with
excitement and well I suppose a lion
mating is rather exciting for them quite
exciting to watch as well and I'm going
to set my clock now and see what's going
on to possess now 1625 that that
happened so let's see if he gets up
again but you saw how she initiated it
she was uninitiated that not him so he's
keen of it anyway are we going to stay
with these lines we're not gonna go
anyway let the action unfold the Niska
see if the rain has stopped in the
Maasai Mara
very good ship very well done and very
interesting to see one male I admit in
with two lionesses
it's nothing out of the ordinary that
happens every in that one then we see
that happening and not much we have
achieved where we are but the good news
are the rains have subsided or rather
the rains have stopped I'll call that
truly very good news and if you look
carefully now my vehicle is not like how
it was before you see mine is showing
you those flaps are up on one side and
also those flaps are also up on the
other side but I've just left windshield
you know right there and the flops in
front just in case that makes it easier
for me now to turn left and turn right
to hopefully get my subsidies I have
already gotten into the public
regardless of the rain and for those of
you would wonder what Republic means is
one area we see a particular pride that
I call the sausage the true pride that
pride has made this place its home it
doesn't move and even if it moves we
don't see anybody else who will come and
occupy this particular area and the
females do not only fight other lions
but they also fight other predators for
example hyenas leopards they do not
entertain any other predator in this
area so we keep looking like this is
because of had told me he thought he saw
a lion as a game Ranger he thought she
saw a lioness with two cups around where
we are nothing as yet but I do not want
to miss anything so have to get my eyes
out
and hopefully I gonna see her well after
having ranged so much chances are they
might have gone under some trees and
Rosalyn how are you you would like to
know how much it's rains in the Mara
what annually in tomorrow we get about a
thousand millimeters of rainfall 1 zero
zero zero annually and that is every
last year Rozlyn chances are I think we
might have gotten more than a thousand
we do not know what amount you'll get
this year but in average we get about a
thousand millimeters of rainfall in a
Rosalyn I will give you a question to
today give me an idea how much rain you
get or you come from I'd be happy to
know and I'm sure you know how to give
me that answer as I keep looking for
that one particular lioness my friend to
me about unless she has moved it was
this particular area we are now so today
I have double challenges the grass as
I'm sure you can see how jollity and
also see how solid grasses and also the
rain I'll have to stick you know in the
middle of the road as far as it will
take and not take chances with the black
cotton soil which could be quite quite a
challenge to try and get out of the big
highway
with secrets of good daylight so I'm not
worried of Darkness illumise the latest
player chances are I'll be able to catch
up with this particular pride
okay devour the chemistry here we have a
lot of black cotton soil and it's not as
tough soil as the blockages well
especially when it rains it gets very
very sticky you have to be very careful
every time you do a move because you
don't want get stuck and when you get
stuck in a four-wheel drive like this
one and you try to come out you try to
spin the tires every time you try
spinning you keep adding yourself so the
best thing we do when you get stuck is
to come out assess you know how stuck
you are and we try and get some branches
and you put on the tires and then you
get some good traction and then you come
out of where you've been stuck
otherwise you once get stuck you don't
panic and you keep pushing the car and
you know putting more gas in it because
you keep digging yourself very good I'm
not getting stuck but I'm sure Trish is
stuck with the Lions
yes I'm marshmallows with the Lions at
the moment
thank goodness not actually marshmallows
I'm so happy that the Dassin hasn't
happened to me yet but
touchwood that there's no wood around
there we go my bottle cap touch wood
that that doesn't happen because last
time I said something doesn't happen
like I said oh I've never broken a foot
before I've never broken a bone and then
what happened I broke one I'm not gonna
say that I'll never get stuck but I'm
glad that I haven't yet and I really
hope that David doesn't get stuck too
especially with that rain at least it's
cleared up a bit I hope that it doesn't
rain here it's looking a bit cloudy and
a little overcast but there is no rain
predicted I think not until the late
evening so we should be good there's our
male on his back relaxing and these two
females are canoodling
Oh boohoo you'd like to know why Lions
lift their legs when they're sleeping
well there's a few theories as to why it
lifts its legs sometimes it's just about
comfort ability maybe they're an awkward
position but one of the more prevalent
theories is that because they're on
their back and they're exposing sort of
the thin thinnest skin on the underneath
and you'll see that their legs sort of
flop apart so that thin skin is on this
is being exposed that they'll actually
be able to cool themselves down easier
with their legs that way now you'll see
that Oh will will see when they start to
mate that the female doesn't as well but
she'll do it in a different way or for
different reason when you see lions just
like this and they're just chilling on
their backs it's probably that they're
trying to cool themselves with that thin
skin but when you see females after
mating rolling on their back it's more
likely that they're trying it's sort of
an instinctual thing they roll on their
back after they mate because apparently
it may help in getting the sperm all the
way up into the lioness so that maybe we
all can get some lion cubs or that the
chance of it may be higher but it seems
to be an instinctual thing they just
kind of roll onto their backs afterwards
but that is the theory it's not actually
very hot in fact I've just put my my
jacket on because I'm feeling a bit
chilly
but obviously this vocal mail is still
feeling a bit warm well if you're going
to be mating the three thousand times
that's probably he's probably worth your
rest zebra and did you say maybe because
it's comfortable yes absolutely I think
that too it might just be a comfortable
position it's not always there's not
always a biological reason for it that
we know of yet it might just be a
comfort well maybe he's just decided
it's a bit itchy on that side I'm gonna
roll over it definitely could just be
that Oh some movement we've got is a
canine sticking out there from one of
the females but that is the extent of
the movement at the moment her lip
flopped down to reveal that kayla was a
massive it was so much excitement it is
it's endless Emma says it's endless I
agree with that
they'll spend most of the day like that
in fact I'm going to take a bet at what
time I think they'll start to move I
think at about quarter to 6:00 that's my
guess it's like I said it's when I was
speaking about the Avoca mail and
talking about him feeling hot or perhaps
feeling warm and that's why he's doing
that is that they're going to mate at
least or estimated Mount amount of about
3,000 times before an actual cub will be
a sired or at least the the males would
and that's I think that's quite
incredible it also gives you an idea of
how much effort it takes to produce one
litter of Cubs and it obviously has to
do with the fact that most of the mating
is in order to induce ovulation in the
females and that once ovulation is
actually induced it's about a 95 percent
chance of that egg actually being
fertilized so most of this mating has a
lot more to do with trying to get that
female to ovulate and then one that once
that's done we can look forward to Cubs
but it's like I said that might take
3,000 mating actual acts
no wonder these guys are tired
that's very true we do have double the
chance with these lions and the ones
with Steve so let's go to him and see if
his have done any exciting things like
reveal canines
mmm juice I'm sitting right here waiting
for some more action to unfold but you
are very right I've got a very strong
suspicion that I don't know exactly when
but at some stage this afternoon no
doubt the two groups are going to join I
have a feeling that will happen and it
might not happen you never know but
there probably are way over the rest
that when Google map riders they
probably all for summer as well Tristan
was telling me earlier that there were
some tracks down towards a SUP of
another single Lion so not sure exactly
there seems to be lions all over the
place
and the wind is coming from our
left-hand side which is a good thing
because well I don't know if it's a good
thing it's a good thing for us because
it means that these lions if they do get
up he'll probably start walking in that
general direction I know some of you out
there don't agree with me but it's
something I see time in and time out so
also there's generally a nice herd of
all the Bears to these days that have
moved back on to the quarantine open
area which is off towards our left-hand
side and always many many impala hello
Joyce you want to know how males find
females and east rest's well they have
they have a twitter account and they
started joking they don't have social
media but they do have their own form of
social media females will urinate and
send mark as well as they go and males
are constantly patrolling their areas
and ever do pick up on any smells of
lions anyway they post they tend to post
or profile left on the corner of
somewhere then they will very quickly
try and find where that lioness is
they've got very good sense of smell and
I've followed a young mare line
following it's pride that was probably
about five or six kilometers away it's
about three four miles away and it found
it by just smelling the ground I wish I
could track like that just sniffing out
the Lions but they've got a very keen
sense of smell and that's just for the
footprints so once there's been a
discharge sore urination or whatever it
might be
the male line will pick that up and
inside his brain suddenly if driver Q
goes and says your everybody there are
there is an e stress female nearby and
the males will push each other out of
the way to get there first and generally
in a coalition you might see a bit of
animosity towards each other but it's
not extremely aggressive when it comes
to Lions Lions can be very very very
tough on each other but coalition
members although they will growl and
snarl and fight each other but they're
generally the first male to find the
females chilly the one who is left with
it although there might be a little bit
of our ji bhaji it's generally not too
serious if it was URI the lion did that
- we'd probably be in quite a lot of
pain but these animals are designed for
hitting and punching and fighting and
clawing and biting each other that's
part and parcel of being a lion and well
if they're not tough enough to do it
they definitely signed up to be the
wrong species and as it starts off from
an early age
competing for mum's milk and every time
they feed on a carcass they have to
compete and by the time they are fully
fledged dominant males have been through
their fair share of confrontations right
now it's not much confrontation
happening and this is um the lioness
with the injured eye again and a few
people on Twitter are suggesting we
should rename her I don't have the power
to rename our Lions or leopards I'm
afraid everybody it is a tricky topic
and for now I'm just going to leave it
as it is they'll wait for James to get
back and maybe he can address that
anyway Tristan is just on the other side
of the reserve looking for any tracks of
Columba let's go and see what he's come
up with
well it's good and bad I mean we haven't
found what we're looking for yet but the
tracks are getting fresher and fresher
for a little mystical iBall I think it's
a and that we're following at the moment
we found that she went to chill a pan
and she's now come down across the
Marathi and is kind of moving eastwards
in general but her tracks are getting
better and better they're on top of
everything they're nice and crisp and
clear and because we've had winter day
you would expect some disturbance on
them but these tracks are kind of
shining a little bit and so I'm hoping
that we're gonna bump into somewhere
around this area just taking it very
very slow because the tracks are almost
impossible to see in places the roads
haven't quite softened up just yet
what's what have we got your sins so
there we go it looks like she walked
here there we go so she's walked on this
left side I'll try pull over so sins can
show you but there's a track that's just
there that's going up this pathway and
she's walking kind of on the road there
you can kind of see that's the tracks
that we're looking for and they're
starting to look really nice and crisp
and clear which is really good news so
hopefully we gonna track her down
it could be Tandy it's possible but I
suspect that this is Columba that we're
following just given where it's come
from I mean it's we've been tracking for
a long time now we've gone a long way so
let's see if we can find it there's a
little pan at the edge here it's got no
warts in it so it's very possible that
she kind of came here to look for water
but because there's no water she might
have moved off naturally it's incredibly
difficult to track her lumber because
she doesn't walk on roads as much scent
marking she's kind of just goes wherever
her heart feels she just kind of bounces
around and crosses roads all over the
place and she's incredibly active she
doesn't sit still for long periods of
time at all which makes finding her and
night me you've got to just kind of be
in the right place at the right time a
lot of it because she just doesn't
really stop and when she does stop she
tends to stop in thicker areas at the
moment
exactly she is a strong independent
lipid that doesn't need anything really
she makes life a little bit tricky in
that regard but it's it's nice because
she is active which means that a lot of
time when lipids are active particularly
young inexperienced lipids they bring
about alarm calls on themselves which
means that if she is moving and she's
close by here somewhere she's going to
spark an alarm call and that's going to
help us and we're gonna be able to then
find it because of that now there's a
part that comes past this sort of dry
pattern that I was talking about and I
just want to double check if she didn't
cross over somewhere here it kind of
goes off in towards this drainage where
she spent a lot of time as a small cub
it doesn't look like she's come over
here we'll just check a little bit
further because sometimes they go over a
little bit further on there's like a
little kind of two track that goes off
to my right now you see she's been up
and down here and has heard of Franklin
I think she's very close I don't think
we're far behind her at all at the
moment the tracks are just starting to
look better and better
looks like they came out yeah I also
part of me is wondering if maybe just
maybe it's not
tungee because this is exactly where we
first had our first visual of Columba in
the den site is where we are right now
so it's very possible that she's maybe
scouting if she is pregnant for possible
dating sites
but these tracks are all over the place
yeah they look like she's been kind of
doing circles which on really is not
definitive in terms of who it actually
is I just want to go down because I
heard a Franco an alarm call here
quickly sighs when a chick right now we
have our work cut out for us especially
where we are now Trish and Steve don't
and so Trish's taking it very easy with
her lions that are lounging away the
afternoon I worked hard to get your
Tristen I promise I drove all the way
from camp it's actually not that far and
we were lucky enough that they were here
in the morning as well as it was not too
much work but I wish Tristan the best of
luck with finding that little one that
would just be awesome it'd be such a
catty
Katty Sunday I'll cheer for us here we
have another view of the Avoca mail now
we think that this is the dark maned
mail often sometimes referred to as the
Crump email Puma you'd like to know how
far away I am from the other Lions
probably not that far prepared to Kay's
not even they're fairly close having the
austell and in juma but this is sort of
in the north west whereas the other
Lions are bit more centrally located but
almost on the same Road but just at
different points in the road so they are
quite close it it almost reminds me of a
bit of a double date you know boys
arrived together the girls arrived
together and then they decided to go to
different movies
they probably met up on tinder like
Steven was saying
it does seem like an awesome day to have
a nap it's just the perfect temperature
just a little little chilly you know
when it's just it's not cold it's just
perfect
mgn you say what about the rest of the
pride well I don't actually know what
the rest of the pride is up to for well
as many as we know as we're accounting
for the four females here and I think
the one other invoker male so we've got
the mohawked one would Steve and I think
I've got the dark mane one here and then
there's the blonde male the blonde male
I think was last seen much more north in
there so I say much more but past the
boundary north of this so they are round
and I'm sure that the rest of the inca
Houmas are around as well but you'll
often find that when they're mating
they'll break away into these pairs or
in this case triplet
very cool so we've got this guy then
we've got the two females that you're
looking at there and we said that one is
the youngest lioness of the program is a
youngest lioness when I say hence you
say it makes you want to take a nap but
definitely makes you want to take a nap
it makes me want to take a nap just
looks so so comfortable now we are
talking about these two so we've got the
youngest lioness as in the youngest
adult lioness and that is tatty yes or
we call it a tear but she's also called
youngest lioness how apt and she was
born in about 2013 and then the other
one that we have is of course the
original female that I have seen mating
with the invoker's before luckily I was
very excited to see that in fact a few
times I think I've seen the originals
female mating with the Evoque I think
once the one time I did see it was with
the dark main male as well but she was
born in 2012 so there's only about a
year between them
so be nice to have a look at their faces
and you have a nice comparison if that
year even makes that much of a
difference in terms of the way that they
look now their vocal males they were all
born in the in 2013 so Ridge nose is a
bit older than him but tatty years our
youngest female she's she's more
age-appropriate but of course none of
that matters in Lion Society in fact a
female will mate with any adult male
that comes along when she's in East hrus
she'll just have to make sure that the
male that she brings into the territory
doesn't attract attention of this one or
in any of the coalition members because
then there will be trouble amongst the
coalition members they will fight for
mating rights within their coalition and
within that pride but they're hardly
ever fights that result in any kind of
serious and injury but if an
a male that's from outside this
territory not part of this coalition
comes in it can be fighting to the death
quite brutal
and you'll actually see the difference
in the way that they fight you can see
one sort of gesture but a bit not
playful but you could see it more
forewarning or this is my lair lioness
stay away whereas when you see them
fighting because they're actually from
two different territories are two
different coalition's it's brutal and
the sound is just incredible
we're all looking for lines today it
seems and for once I think we've got the
Lions before David has but I have no
doubt that he will also find some lions
because he's special like that so let's
go up to the masai mara well Trish My
Luck has not come yet I'm still working
very hard hopefully to see the sausage
of fried but yes as you say it's quite
brutal to see a lot of fights but that's
what it's meant to be the male's will
always go for each other especially
during takeovers the lords and that's
mine speak of a picture male that used
to reign in this territory of the
sausages but Oh Scotty pulley which I
think up now is one man I respect
because in one day I so keep fighting
two males in one day one in the morning
and one in the afternoon the good news
is he won't both battles as much as he
incurred a very big scar I think on his
right side on his radar
I got a huge I figured a claw mark but
he warned you don't want sea lions
fighting but of course if they fight for
good reason why not
now initially my flaps on the left to
the Marquez race subsided and the ones
on the right and now the front it's all
clear so the only job me and man who
have now is get Lions we have no excuse
not to get them
we have no reason not to see the
violence but just can if you look on the
right there you can see the kind of
clouds we got money gonna show the
viewers how the clouds look like there
and you can still hear the thunderstorms
going and I hope you can hear the rains
or thunderstorms going there anyhow this
is such the Republic not a single drop
now what you only seeing is a bit of
lightning needle in the sky shoot shoot
going and coming and then of course
should we have for that we hear
thunderstorms which is very normal
that's how the sequence goes first
listening followed by thunderstorms and
we are here to try and smoke these Lions
out my friend who taught me had seen a
lioness around this area
he's a camera and I'm really counting on
him so much not that I doubted him but
most likely that one female he saw would
have risen up and maybe walked away so
I'm deciding to look at this area
because sometimes move very fast
so money sent we did something with my
audio let me just check what could be
happening
I think either my comms are not getting
tomorrow very well everything seems to
be in place Martin just make it a little
tighter better now he's happy all right
why you never know what happens in
communications okay
left right see you can either smell
these files I'm sure definitely not
after the race
let me first send you back to zero
David I don't worry about lions
these lions are fast asleep I'm hoping
at some stage they're going to get up
and do something but the longer they
hold off doing anything well the longer
we can probably stay with them because
you know how quickly these lions can
move and cover quite a lot of distance
if they do start moving and if they are
hungry well they can move and move and
move and talk they secure some food but
it's an interesting situation Arian now
because essentially there is one male
mating the two females so are they even
hungry at all the purple eyed lioness
was definitely hungry this morning due
to the fact that she was hunting but
maybe it was also because she didn't
have a consort with him at the time and
well now she's yawning again maybe we're
gonna see it getting up again everybody
this is what heralded the loss mating
session and it has been exactly 50
minutes so definitely not an intense
sort of situation going on here Oh gotta
scratch yourself that looks very nice
you scratch my back aah and I'll just
scratch my own back you see a couple of
the wounds on the back there's some old
wounds a lot of those up I received from
fighting around kills sorry em how it's
Joe asked a question about the
sub-adults I didn't quite quite get all
of that question there but one thing I
can tell you for sure is the young males
of the warmer would not want to be
anywhere near yes of course so Joe thus
about us not necessarily but the males
the young males definitely would be at
very very high risk and the
incorporators just sort of accepted that
mundane email now and so I don't think
they were anyone to just throw him to
the wolves as it were so probably there
would have been some form of calling
some form of connection with the Avoca
males and the rest the prior to probably
just disappeared elsewhere it's possible
they've gone south I'm Tristan says he's
got tracks all the way around treehouse
dam area so we didn't actually spend any
time tracking this morning myself and
said we came out too we went and while
we did a little bit of tracking but who
would directly eat a West from where we
are got the drone up in the air no
tracks where we had been and then we
found these lines using the thermal
drone so if there is the pride had come
in before we hadn't seen any sign of
that so I don't know where they are they
could be south of us they could stop in
North it's very hard to say but one
thing's for certain the young males
wouldn't want any part of these Avoca
boys that is for sure because
unfortunately the reality is and we
don't even know it happened maybe the
vocal males got into it with those two
young males and maybe they've been
chased maybe there's been a fight we
don't know so it's crazy to see it
because you never actually know it goes
on while you're not watching if indeed
there's been some interaction between
the females and the young males you
probably wouldn't see too much of the in
the way of injury when the two of okar
males and from what I saw this morning I
didn't see any fresh
sort of science or they a number of sort
of nourish scars but nothing from the
last day or so
so if indeed those two youngsters young
males of the goomar pride that includes
the monk any male if they even saw these
evoke commands they would just take off
there's no point standing their ground
they'll just get a hiding but then up in
the mara last year we saw a pulley move
into the sausage tree pride and accept
those two young sausage tree pride males
so things do happen you never know what
could happen but what I've experienced
in the past is when a big male lion
comes across a young males they're
generally head for the hills and quite
often you can even see the prides
behavior we saw them goomers last year
when the Birmingham's had moved south
their voters were establishing a sort of
the the rain in the north and you'd hear
them calling and the in coomer's would
all stand up and walk in the opposite
direction I've seen that many times
before with prides that have got sub
adults especially young males they're
just moved in another way that I want to
lose their genetics but then eventually
the desire to mate kicks in with a
driver the East recycle and essentially
the females then will seek out the
dominant males don't want to mate with
the subordinate males with males that
haven't established themselves haven't
proven their worth that's one of the
reasons what conception is Lions is a
very very low James I haven't heard
anything about the Birmingham boys as
far as I'm aware now they're still doing
very well down in the south
I haven't to be paid any too much
attention to their Facebook profiles
those of you didn't know most of our
animals have got some form of Facebook
profile and this one is trying to do a
very interesting licking but back now
how many of you can do that
yoga teachers out there can you lick
your back very long tongue so I'm sure
the Birmingham's are down south I'll
have a little look-see now and see
there's anything going on but they
haven't come north that's for sure
haven't heard of any any movements of
them up towards us sort of the areas of
Chitra and the areas sort of just south
of us they seem to be quite happy in
their pride lands now in the sort of
South essential parts of the sabi sands
where they are very very good game
numbers permanent water and in the form
of the sabi and the sand her that I
think they quite happy down there
well very good
so no one has yet admitted to being as
flexible as this line and being able to
buy to their own lick their own back
she's being irritated to buy some flyers
now must be a constant source of
irritation as a lion having flies
constantly just buzzing around your face
albeit with the rains having seemingly
passed most of the flies have kind of
head for the hills where I was looking a
little bit closer at the male lions
bottom earlier and that looked quite
inflamed with a number of the Flyers on
it so don't know exactly what's happened
there but let's jump over to Trish who's
about a kilometer to Murata inside and
see if her lives are giving us any more
action than these three well the flies
haven't managed to get here yet and they
haven't done anything to make my Lions
move but I'm slightly thankful because
at least it like the Flyers are not
gonna bother me because they can be
quite irritating when you're sitting in
the lion sighting especially when you
have a whole lot of biting flies trying
to eat at you so good luck Steve to deal
with that cuz that's coming once they
start irritating the Lions you see the
occasional flick of the yeah oh there we
have one little fly landed there we go
Lions hosts so many pests it seems like
they're constantly riddled with
something or the other if it's not flies
sometimes there's mange in fact speaking
of mange and Steve was telling you about
how sub-adults would like to be far away
I'm sure those one Guinea or that one
monkey an email would want to be very
far away away from this big male this of
Elka male who might decide to chase him
away and I think for an animal like that
that is so oh not as vulnerable but
definitely still recovering he is
looking great compared to what he was
looking like I was actually surprised
when I saw him and and how much better
he's looking but even for him I suppose
he's not totally 100% healed but he's
hair and tail tuft and Mane is starting
to grow back just a little so I think
you might be feeling a bit vulnerable
and the last thing he needs is a big
main dominant lion coming after him so
they will be far far away
you wouldn't say these floppy lazy cats
are actually quite efficient killing
machines
I couldn't quite get the name then I
must apologize because I am sounding a
bit muffled today or rather FC is
sounding a bit muffled to me today but I
did get the question the question was if
there was a higher mortality in Cubs if
because of mange I suppose I mean that
could be but mostly the problem with
Cubs in the fact that they have such a
high mortality rate in lots of big cats
is the fact that no male that comes into
a situation wants to be taking care of
Cubs that are not his own so the biggest
threat to them are other males that are
gonna come in and very likely kill them
to bring their mothers into Easter so
that she can actually have his own Cubs
in terms of mange mange being a problem
now mange is a mite that buries itself
into the skin and I suppose Cubs could
get mange but mange is not really going
to not going to kill you what's going to
kill you is the deterioration of the
body once mange has infected you so it's
a mange does get a cub or two I don't
think it will really shift shift the
stats to say that maybe mange is causing
a high mortality it's mostly because of
other males that may come in or
infanticide as you might have heard
before
and of course availability of food
because a lot of the time you'll find
that especially with lions
Cubs eat last and they often don't eat
at all because there might not be
anything left oh there was a bit of a
yawn there from one male starting to
move but of a stretch Oh could it be
time
yes but potala tea is is really really
high in lots of these cats and after
about a year all that starts to drop
quite drastically
and cats actually tend to be weaned
quite earlier and earlier than say a
hyena heinous hyenas feeds their young
milk up into about a year and a half in
some in some cases whereas lion cubs
you're more looking at about 7 to 9
months old that they're going to be
weaned by by vehicle that's the sound
that you're hearing of a vehicle start
up Oh a big yawn they're so already
between at about 7 to 9 months when they
are weaned oh it seems that Steve's
lioness is up so let's go to him and
we'll carry on our cover and weaning
discussion in a moment
Thank You Trish just in time everybody
forty-two minutes since the last one
that was the purple I'd Linus again he
was having a little bit of an
interesting time with her tail before
she stood up and she was flicking a tail
and trying to bite it and then she
prostrated herself in front of him and
now they are flat again rolling over to
potentially try and assist in the
possible fertilization at something you
often see in big cats after mating their
roll over but such strange sounds aren't
there from that male that sort of harsh
squeaking sound I don't really know what
it's about but there's a very
interesting nonetheless and you can't
just just in time there cuz not much it
happened before she was busy grooming
herself and then
perfect timing
mambas hasn't even raised her head as
you can see how well camouflage they are
they can't you and the Tony cats in the
Tony gross
hello magic dragon wizard and that most
amount of Cubs that I've seen was five
they were initially six but it didn't
survive early stages so five and there
were two lionesses that had five at a
very similar stage amazing how quickly
you can grow the prides numbers when you
have such numbers but that was in a very
high resource rich area whereby there is
enormous numbers of buffalo zebra anvil
the best so I have no doubt that food
resource it's also an important driving
force behind the number of lion cubs
that are born but then I might be
completely wrong there I mean you can
see how the sausage tree Prada is
producing sorry save my break is on up
to apologize sausage tree pride is
producing but the most that they getting
me is three so six have been recorded
with Lions it's not very often that you
see it and whether they do survive that
early stages is also quite tricky
because we know how difficult it is for
lion cubs in those very early stages but
not like wild dogs that can have many
many many pups they grow their
population very quickly where reckoner
takes a very long time to successfully
reintroduce individual Lions into the
population and obviously good parenting
and but as hasn't done them very well
and purple are lioness I do believe has
been successful
and I'm thinking she wants to be
successful again so she has had three
cups that we know about the first that
set was introduced to the Pratt and was
first seen in 6th of July in 2016 and
that is a long time again so one of them
is a male and two females she is indeed
the mum of out uncle Huma young male
and hopefully she will be able to
provide us with symbol cuteness okay
well it sounds as if Trish Allah's Lions
have not beaten us to the punch because
we had some action they are so just
having a little bit of a snooze
afterwards but there's up in Mobile
let's good see which direction they're
gonna hit oh it seems it is contagious
and you Steve may say that as a joke but
he knows exactly what he's saying if the
behavior is if often termed contagious
because it happens so much when the
animal when one animal gets up starts to
scratch lick start to defecate and
urinate and that's usually a sign that
things are going to be there's gonna be
some action happening soon Oh mr. mail
here has just just realized that these
females have woken up here bit late but
heshes moved just a little bit's and the
other ones gonna move now - oh look at
that stretch I'm sure that reminds you a
lot of your house cat just on the most
steroids you've ever seen
Raymond you'd like to oh you think that
this mail looks a bit scrawny there's
something wrong with him
he doesn't look at too bad he is he is a
bit thin but he might not have been
eating very well during this time of
mating but his condition looks quite
good Oh see some teeth now we're talking
about aging as well when you saw there
and he opened his mouth you would have
seen his teeth a slightly yellow or they
starting to yellow a little bit and
that's also indication of age how older
a lion gets the yellower
their teeth will get cute
I love a male lion it's just one of the
most beautiful oh and look at that one
of those beautiful animals really
magnificent oh oh you had bit of his
main caught in his teeth bit give it a
nice scratch now we will continue our
Cubs and weeding and a like discussion
soon I just want to see he's actually
going to get up to follow these females
who are now behind the car and I can't
actually see them very clearly but they
did move behind I don't know if they've
moved further but he will not let them
out of his sight so as long as I stick
with him we should be fine he was just
the last one to wake up as well
the other two got up and he didn't seem
to realize that these females were
moving hello you handsome thing oh they
start around she hear that sneeze
now you'll often see that the male's
will actually follow females so intently
that they kind of step on each other's
feet which is quite hilarious to watch
actually it's amazing to watch this sort
of beast kind of be doting on these
females and behaving so innocently
giving himself a bit of a groom I
suppose with all the pests around it's
not an that's probably a good thing for
him
Gina you say he's a player oh look at
that Gina he's giving you a full look at
exactly his stature so he's I think he
agrees with you I'm the player yo I feel
that definitely walking my vehicle so
they have moved behind me at the moment
so I'm going to have to do the same just
excuse our aerial there you can see
Craig's had fall him all the and you
stopped to look so I'm gonna move around
a little bit but they're very unlikely
to go far at all
they're probably just just move position
slightly I've noticed that a lot when
they mate
there was sort of move a few meters than
a few meters just also want to be
careful as as I reverse because there
was a small pile of Lion who and that's
last thing you want in your tires anyway
let me get into a better position oh no
no don't do it don't do it they're about
to mate they're about to mate Oh No
false alarm false alarm everybody so let
me send you up to David in the Maasai
Mara with the sunset
very good Trisha I can tell you here
we're just swimming in the mud in the
black cotton soil because it has gotten
stickier where we are and especially
when you're going uphill they become
stuff I think I'm better off dealing
with mattress that you're dealing with a
layin poo because mud is what sometimes
I call clean - you know in general most
Oh poof of Matt Cutts or what she calls
cuts you know I the cheetah who live for
the Lions of a very strong smell very
strong you know stench
and for me I'm better off dealing with
you know elephant dung or radar or zebra
tongue but anything dropped by cuts is
always very powerful in terms of smell
just because of what they eat the
important it has generally I do not
think they digest it very well and I'm
thinking because of the amino acids in
the meat that they eat
I'm silly the Republic not going
anywhere and I have a lot of time to do
what I want
it's getting sometimes a bit muddy I
have to put my four-wheel drive
especially in this particular area I'm
coming too so what I have to do
sometimes just to prepare well I just
put it up Momentum's before I get to the
very sticky part in a momentum to keep
going
they said earlier the top of the long
grass the rains of course the mud have
compounded my situation but what you do
and gets freeze up it's just to stop
somewhere and just listen for any calls
from the Alliance because once it's
rains most of the scent marking
including even full outputs it's always
washed away by the rain and most cats
will always have to resent again just to
make sure that the the males of a verse
know this area is occupied of course if
the Lions and the same case would happen
to leopards let's find out if this
violence in Juma on the move
yes everybody so I was keeping quiet
there just you came just in time for the
action once again and that is the purple
I lioness amber ours has just moved off
so that was 15 minutes
very interesting that's normal sort of
time about 15 minutes or so
and buyers stood up and walked away
but this young lady is a little bit more
interested than he is
well then she is I'm sorry be sorry
Sonny getting very busy here this
afternoon we are just next to our main
road or very till access and so it's a
few vehicles coming to have a look of
course so we managed to get a third
mating session
very good maybe she's building up to it
everybody but amber Aizen has
disappeared behind us and maybe she's
decided she wants to go and get herself
a summit an app just like Trish's
lionesses it almost seems like they're
on the same sort of alarm clock
temperatures really nice and cooled
right now
hello Safari lover well lines can walk
and five they want to while their mate
they can also stay in the same area it
really depends on on the needs you know
there pas people drink during their
mating so if there's water nearby
there's no need for them to walk but
essentially what we normally see here is
when you do have a mating pair that
often sort of hang out in the same sort
of area they don't walk too far and if
they're due it's probably got to do with
the fact that maybe there's a little bit
of hunger developing or they're
following someone or it's towards the
beginning or the end of the actual
intense mating session when I was with
the kinky tail up in the Mara she didn't
leave sort of them the one area for that
entire table she was there but there was
plenty of water nearby so that's the one
thing that would probably make them move
while they're in that sort of that
mating cycle eventually it's the desire
to eat that leads them to completely
leave the mating circle all together the
amber eyes is having none of it
can you still see ridore sip on him we
thought it would just stay with these
two
he's behind the bush of course we will
reposition short key we've just got
ourselves into a little bit of a
roadblock for now
and that is the weight and it works
sometimes
okay well why are we trying to probably
get you a better view gonna send you
over the Tristan who I believe had a
little bit more information about a
leopard he's on the trail off well
unfortunately I wish I had better news
for you because we just found a leopard
on foot but it ran away and I cannot for
the life of me find it with the vehicle
and we've searched high and low and
unfortunately I was tracking it through
this horrible block that we're in and
she was ahead of me and then kind of
walked pass and luckily sins are
actually got a view of her as well so
it's kind of roughly either direction at
we hating at the moment but I don't know
if we going to be able to find her in
fact I think maybe we'll all save and
Steve to help us with the drone just now
and see if we can get some sort of kind
of action there but I'll play you a
little replay if you want to since will
you play them a replay so just be cold
on and there's going to be a little bit
of a filmstrip kind of thing that you're
gonna see maybe you guys can tell me
which lifted this detection he is so
since I was going to show you quickly
from his recording that he made very
heavily in two seconds of us kind of
well-loved me sort of walking and sins
actually sort of paying attention so
sins is gonna play it now so I'm ready
I think I stands out even goes
you see it yeah checks ours others I saw
her that is pretty much what regards
unfortunately so if any of you can ID
from that shot be quite impressed but
basically what had happened is I was on
the tracks following and I was going
through a big dump and as I came up I
just saw that he is pointing and then
she obviously saw me and then she went
trotting off and passenger and since I
managed to see her coming past and so
since I was quick and sharp enough to be
able to actually record who it was I
suspect it's Columba but it could be
tündi too so maybe some of you can go
back and try and get a screenshot and
just work arts exactly who it is but I
mean we tried really hard to kind of
find her with the vehicle I mean you can
see what it looks like on the right hand
side yeah it is really not something you
want to spend a lot of time in and so I
think unfortunately we're not gonna have
much luck so Sammy Jane it was elusive
but it's it's one of our normal females
it's just unfortunately she saw me on
foot before I did and so she's and she
didn't like it's not like she was
running for her life out of there just
doing what lipids do when they get seen
as they kind of truck off to thickets
and then they sit there and they kind of
hide away so no darts are just driven
around - it's so dense in there that
there's so many little hidey holes that
potentially this leopard could be at
that you know it's possible that she's
right there and I've just driven faster
again so anyway it is what it is I mean
you know it's getting dark now so I
can't really go back on foot and try and
kind of find her again from your tracks
plus that leopard now is gonna be so
alert to any presence that if I walk
there she's just gonna keep running from
me and it's not really gonna work no I
don't think so I think I just got closer
than that lipid thought I would be H
because what happened was cuz we
followed the tracks and it was some Jana
that were very relaxed and I kind of
lost the track there and we came back
and then I figured out the tracks again
and got down into this dub
and the tracks were really really really
fresh and they went up onto this rise
and I wasn't expecting this little mud
water further on from that pathway so I
was expecting maybe that that lipid
would be there and so as I came up she
was close I mean she was maybe I don't
know but even in five maybe four five he
meets his sort of ten meters away from
where I was and obviously just gave her
a little bit of a fright she didn't
expect me to pop up right there and so
that's what's happened unfortunately it
does happen from time to time with
tracking that's one of the hard parts of
being on foot is that sometimes if
there's not a kill or something like
that the lipid can get a little shy and
just kind of sneak off but I feel like
it's it's a frustration because it was a
job well done we tracked a long long way
together and then unfortunately just
didn't find it at the car to show all of
you as yet but like I said maybe serving
Steve can help us with the drone if they
get it up here fairly shortly then we
might get lucky I'm gonna keep trying
I'm not gonna give up just yet I'm gonna
do some loops around here listen for
some alarm calls maybe I'll get lucky
and I'll find her again in the meantime
though it's send you back across to
Trish Allah and her lions whoo well I'm
not being so lazy this afternoon well I
really hope you do get lucky the
meantime because my lions have been a
good to us in they're a lot less shy you
would say considering that they having a
bit of a mating storm at the moment all
out in the open for all of us to see now
isn't that a handsome handsome man look
at him actually lion not a man tend to
call them all men and women I don't know
why I just feel like I know them better
when I do but of course it is a handsome
lion
if you look at that main look how well
it actually camouflages in the brown of
the grass so when the grass is nice and
brown like this he fits in so well and
even though he is the dark main male his
Mane is not as dark as it could be or
that I've seen other lions have in fact
one of the theories is that males or the
reason or one of the reasons why females
do a lot of the hunting and males even
though it's a bit of it's a myth
actually not a bit of a myth it is a
myth that males or that females
exclusively hunt they don't males will
also hunt when they need to and when
what are they gonna do when it's three
of them in a coalition and the pride is
nowhere to be seen it's just more
convenient if the females hunt and they
get to get to take some of it but one of
the theories is then the main actually
makes the animal look more conspicuous
when it's out in the in the bush and so
it's easily identifiable to any sort of
prey item in that the females have a
better success because they don't have
this Mane to sort of lug around with
them and that makes it obvious or makes
them obvious amongst the foliage nothing
again I don't know if I if I really
believe that I mean it has a lot to do
with this may seem strange but but they
I mean people are always after bad boys
in a way simply you say that gorgeous
simply gorgeous he is absolutely
gorgeous so when I say that females in
general like bad boys it applies quite
biologically it's not simply something
that your mother tells you to try and to
tell you actually the riskier a male is
the more attractive he looks or peers
because it means that despite his risk
like birds that will sing out in a
really open place it's very risky
something might just come in but take it
a lion with a very dark mane big dark
mane is very conspicuous he'll be seen
but despite that they are alive so
that's the one I want to mate with
because he's got the strongest genes
that can really he can be risky and
nothing is going to happen to him so
that attraction to bad boys is not not
just a bad habit by females of the human
race ah yes I am - Emma says that she's
imagining him in a leather jacket I can
see it - I can see him get on his bike
not say a word to my parents as I jump
on and my parents looked shocked at me
as we drive away me and the Evoque Emile
yes him in his leather jacket in mine in
my leather tights
I think he prefers lions it's after that
story he put his head down to very
unimpressed
now the females are not too far away at
all they're just behind us and they're
never more than a few metres apart when
they're mating and no matter what he's
gotten I or a smell of their location at
all times
in fact just before he ended up here he
was a but I out of eyesight range for
these females but then he went to a bush
in he smelt them or smelt where they had
sent marked and he gave us some lovely
Flemming grimaces he looked straight at
us and gave that snarl associated with
the Flemming grimace and that of course
is all part of the intricate dance that
is the mating ritual with lions
look at those eyes so intense the face
is so intense and I love it anyway I'm
going to sit with them I might go and
see the females they're right behind us
we can kind of swap between them in the
meantime let me send you over to Tristan
oh did you hear Tristan's name and you
picked your head up since you over to
Tristan on the search for his leopard
trying very hard funny enough I chicks
just because I was thinking maybe just
maybe that this could be Tandy and the
fact that the tracks are going up and
down up and down here one day she was
like I was saying she's not looking for
a den site potentially and
I went and checked the den where we
first ever saw Trey lumber yeah I'm just
in case before we walked on foot to find
way she was and there's no sign of her
going in and out sigh Winston checks the
drainage line and doesn't look like
she's been going there but it was just
an off chance and James Richard Urich
and that it could very well be a ton d
that we bumped into just now on foot
which would explain why she's run
Columba while she might move come on
rusty while she might move isn't as shy
as her mom funny enough on foot so well
got at least in the last few times that
I found her on foot so that explains a
lot so it also explains why I can't find
her again because she's too clever for
me now that I've found her once she's
almost as if to say you won't find me
again interestingly enough though there
was tracks when we lost her I had a
quick look around just trying to see
which direction she went and these
tracks all around me going up and down
so I don't know maybe they could I
suppose be a carcass there there could
be any sort of reason for her to spend a
lot of time in that area and so I'm just
slowly now driving in areas that I think
she might pop art given her normal
movement and I want to do a little track
it goes back to where I saw her that
runs along the drainage line she often
uses this and her and Claire lumber used
to use this regularly they used to kind
of cut in and out of this area and so
I'm hoping that if I can find her then
you know we're gonna be good and like I
say seven Steve are gonna come to our
aid with the drone fairly shortly which
is really gonna probably help a lot if
she's moving if she's not moving and we
have a tricky but if she's moving we
should be good and we hopefully we'll be
able to have some luck to be able to
find this lipid for you guys before the
end of show which I know is not very
long except that you'll be with us for
the TV show - sir it's important that we
try to find it and I'm also intrigued to
see what's going on with Tandy so let's
see how we got in the meantime that
seems you up to David and the Mara see
how he's getting on and whether he's
moving coping saw them might on that
side of the world very good luck
Tristana stallion hopefully you're going
to see the Queen of jummah at one point
and my search continues for the surgeon
surprised and I just thought I'll just
stop for once and pause and listen and
enjoy that rainbow there which is
looking very colorful I do not remember
the last time I saw a rainbow this lit I
when I sell it I'm talking about six
thirty
East African time and to see rainbows
this late this I mean in this darkness
is quite special still amount of light
out there and that is very colorful I'm
definitely guranteed I'm not going to
see the Sun Saturday but how cool to see
the rainbow after quite a long time and
don't we lost him I saw a rainbow here
in the morrow track well we really
should see them once in a while what a
thing could be over a month and yes and
yeah I'm in the final control saying
it's stunning and you can see the usual
a conic a chef at the trees of the model
triangle making everything looking
beautiful and to the left of the screen
and that is the oh la la la escapement
sometimes when you see rainbows we shall
say that could be a little pose for the
rains and then after the rainbow
disappears rains will come again so
hopefully
he'll give us good break for the rest of
the drive to search for my liens but you
really need the range to come because
they want a lot of water in the Mara
River where the levels have gone low but
the good news are there was a slowly
rising now at last - its Austria and
you're saying I'm in a Jeremiah yeah
good to hear you've seen the fire
rainbow rainbow very good Jeremy a great
coming down
I hope Jeremiah you see same rainy Bush
where you come from but all it's good to
see rainbow mana when is the last time
you saw a rainbow yeah Jeremiah man
who's the camera operated me today and
he's telling me he's four months ago
since he saw a rainbow because in
general we see rain was generally rain
and four months ago takes us back to
December when we had the short rains
makes a lot of sense and I think
possibly you could at the same time I
also saw the last rainbow not to the
left of the rainbow if you look
carefully you can see a bit of rain not
sure the other one should be a second
rainbow reflection on the first one I
looks like a leaf flex on the first one
because once a while it was in two
rainbows but I went order meant to say
is we look on the owners coming
carefully you can see a bit of rain not
as much but what you see there looking
like mist that shows more rainfall in
that particular area still quite
stunning great views watch here should
be reflection of the other rainbow if
not too
James Richard how are you and you want
to know about the Murray River and the
migration and all that well it's a bit
affects the migration but what I'm
trying to say here James Richard the
will miss will symptom away this will
come but the migration will still be
done all the crossing of the river is
like it would be more over an empty
river are we just gonna see them just
walking through without the water so
it's a very not effects to my aggression
because mainly they wildebeest will come
here for the food not for the my river
crossing and of course we all know we'll
always cross the river to get food on
the other side so just reach a good
question and of course always a pleasure
to hear your name James so James which
I'm sure you can remember I know you
follow us very closely this is exactly
where King tell drops have three clubs
and that's why I came here because I've
been looking around I haven't seen them
and that was in the month of February so
I'm trying to imagine if there could be
struggling to come back home they could
be here and telling me this is not where
they are they have since been moving
around moving a lot so because of course
of the Buffaloes would have been looking
for and that makes them look or move for
so many kilometres well good view of the
rainbow there let's go back to Trish and
find out how Hawaiians are doing
oh good luck David I am so sure you will
find those sausages and I don't know
them to ever shy away from you
this guy is definitely not shy I've got
another vehicle joining us and they've
all got their cameras out and he's
looking straight at them as if he's at a
photo shoot and what I particularly
liked is he walked up from where we were
just earlier and walked straight to the
middle of the main road and sat down and
decided let everybody know exactly why
he is in charge here at Juma so at the
moment no vehicles can pass on the main
road because he is smack bang in the
middle why because he can because he is
a bad boy yes he is it's also because
he's a lion and he likes the warmth of
the road
Oh Barbara you'd like to know what
happened to the male with the wound on
his face that I found I remember that it
was but a month or two back now I think
Barbara well I'd be really interested to
find to find him but this is not him it
was the blonde Avoca that had the bite
in his head that round using wound that
we saw quite a few times remember he was
also looking quite skinny then but he is
the blond one the one that has not she
at the moment but the blond one has been
seen so nothing's happened to him he's
still fine is alive he's kicking and he
seems to be healthy as far as we know
but I would love to see him and see how
that's closed up because that seemed
like quite a wound considering I mean it
was basically a puncture on his on his
forehead that we had seen and it was
really I mean it was it was small but
the problem was it looked really deep
and it was right on the skull so we
don't know what other sort of damage it
had done but he seemed to function to
function fine but he was looking really
really skinny around that time
so they're the females up now there's
one here and this one on the other side
of the male mgn you'd like to know if
lions shed their hair they certainly do
in the same way as most mammals do here
for hairs
drop and grow all the time and you know
that it's the same for you as well
and that's just a natural process and
you'll find it in fact when you're
looking close in to the lion actually
licking itself you'll see bits of hair
actually pull out I have once even seen
sort of a bit of a Mane or part of the
main that sort of looked looked like
like a dreadlock a little bit that had
been pulled off the lion and was found
right on the floor so they can
definitely do his head and it's even
worse if they're having a fight and then
you'll see lots of bits okay on the
ground and the time that I'm telling you
about when I saw that bit of Mane on the
ground that was from a meeting incidence
after he after he dismounted and she
decided of course she's got to give him
the ceremonial smack otherwise it's just
not right is it but you'll find that
even that's smack sometimes it will
happen sometimes it won't usually if
they just recently mating as and they've
only gotten together in a day or two
then you'll find that she can still be
quite skittish and she will actually
swipe at him quite a bit but when
they've been meeting for a while then
that tends to happen less since she just
sort of moves off to the sides just will
give a growl and a bit of a stall but
that's about it so that's actually a
good indication once we actually see
them mating to be able to tell how long
they've been mating together
well my lions are going nowhere I know
they're right shell on the boundary
there so basically sitting or listen
oh that was that was amazing wasn't that
lovely I'll do excuse the vehicles that
are there because everyone would see
wants to be in this amazing sighting you
can see they've also got their lights
out
oh and everyone's on the move which
means I've gotta be on the move as well
now I'd like to wait for the mail to
move because when he's gonna move there
we go that's my cue he seems to have a
bit of a limp going on there you know
all the other vehicles gearing up to
move as well
now I'm actually going to have to move
around because there are a number of
vehicles in the sighting right now so
let me see exactly how I'm going to do
this luckily for us they seem to be ten
it seemed to have turned East into Juma
which is just perfect for us all right I
am on the search again but I know that
they're not far away at all
unfortunately that even is not as lucky
but like I said he definitely will find
those sausages let's go to him just
don't let those slaves out of your eyes
because and that's tomorrow where we
have this vana the landscape is very
different with all flowers as much as we
have
and as much as you have the long grass
are a theme of week quicklink
well perseverance has paid off so just
as Steve and saber arrived with the
drone we managed to bump into with the
car exactly where I found on foot so we
decided to come all the way back just in
case and there is the Queen sitting
right there so oh that was quite an
off-roading mission I think I've
probably put many a Dame's inside
Rusty's body work during the course of
this afternoon but success and at least
we've managed to find her like I said it
was a long track to get to I mean she's
walked all the way from Rebecca's - yeah
which probably is meaningless to most of
you but it's about in terms of walking
time would be probably about a two hour
walk if you had to track but she looks
like she's kind of watching down below
there I wonder if she maybe doesn't have
a kill here somewhere um where she's
looking down is exactly where I was
coming up when she spotted me earlier
and where she kind of moved off from now
but let's see maybe she's got some sort
of food item you can see are difficult
the terrain is here though I mean it's
really almost impossible to get any sort
of view of her so I'm gonna try just
also not kill us because there's a very
big bank yeah
since can you still see her yes she's
there okay so I'm trying to see it's
getting so dark now what's I can't see
with my eye but she's somewhere they
where the spotlights is now I believe in
lots of you saying good job well I think
it's mostly sensor is kind of keen I
that made sure that he saw where she
went and that gave us an idea of where
to work around and eventually we kind of
got it what have you got there my girl
have you got a kill yes you've got a
kill what a clever girl so he would have
found it eventually she's got to kill
how cool is that awesome and there's a
real Ettore right yeah so hopefully
she's gonna drag it to this marula tree
they are hyenas around so I'm gonna keep
my spotlights and all my car lights off
so that we don't attract any attention
obviously with lights on hyenas will
come in check what's going on and we
actually did passing Timur way up when
you saw me turning off the road just
after I sent you off earlier and I had a
brief video of her walking past me so I
don't want to kind of
in any way whatsoever while having the
lights on and trying to keep his kind of
sort of still as possible and lights off
for as long as possible to make sure
that we don't attract any attention
towards her spotlights often hyenas will
follow a spotlight in a block because
they know that they could potentially be
a food item but this is super exciting
that we've managed to locate her on a
kill
it's definitely hopefully going to be a
decent-sized kill that maybe we've got
her for the next couple days and that'll
give us a really good chance to kind of
see what's actually going on with ten
years she possibly pregnant what's going
on in terms of her sort of stomach and
hopefully that's gonna kind of be a good
indicator as to what we can expect going
forward I suspect maybe she might be
pregnant
she's been awfully round every time
we've been seeing her and so that really
kind of means that you know it could be
something inside giraffe girl you say
it's an Easter feast oh we've been
spotted this afternoon having to be I
mean to have two sets of lions and jima
which is unheard of really even though I
know the in coomer's are kind of one
grouping but to have two different
sightings is unheard of and then on top
of that yes you can go into our sends
you more than welcome to because getting
very dark she's going down towards the
drainage into a horrible tree of course
she is which is came to make my life
almost impossible I'm just watching her
dragging it down below their sins I
think let's try and kind of figure out a
way to get to where she is I'm gonna
have to try and cross back over we I
don't know how I'm gonna do this I guess
let's try and figure out how we gonna
get there because where she's gone now
is very unfriendly but it is a kind of
way it's going to be safer for her can
you see yeah no we can't go that way and
unfortunately so sins are saying we
could try go the other side but I don't
think we're gonna be able to get down
there so I'm gonna try go this way
unfortunately we can't drive in the
drainage line we have to go over the
drainage line and then drive on the
other side for a little bit and then
hopefully she's gonna be very kind to us
and she's not going to take it the wrong
way
and come back onto this side because
down there is really difficult to be
able to negotiate since we did we come
through we came through this rain right
so now I'm gonna try and figure out how
to get back to where Tandy's gone in the
meantime though that sends you back
across to David and see how he's getting
on how exciting is that's the tandy of
the queen of jummah has been sported
hopefully she'll be sports it again and
maybe come back to her killer you know
if she got a kid who stood in a tree
well I was talking earlier fish ala with
her lions which were on the move and I
was saying it's a lot easier for us here
to follow lions wanna start moving
because we have the flatness of the you
know of the landscape and of course I'll
[ __ ] have a little long grass we can
still maybe follow the Lions but in Juma
the vegetation there is totally
different
well two things have happened here since
number one it just I'll just tweet again
and you can see I got to my winch in the
back I'm here to start using my wafer
and of course it has gotten a bit dark
and of course that means over translates
for us having gone to infrared well I
haven't given up in the bush you never
say never until the very last minute
when you're out of here that's when
you're like okay these cuts
not showing up in general the sausages
every other time we'll say 910 times
when they come looking for them I'll
always get them but that one time or the
10 times is always a challenge so what
will happen is we start getting my
spotlight and use it the only thing is
if it's pitching like this chances are
we'll be somewhere either under a tree
or in some kind of cave or some rocks or
in very good thickets protecting the
babies from the rain I mean it's 10 Cubs
and Kinki having the youngest three caps
they don't want to get chances with rain
because you have known you know lions
will get flu will get cold
you know Cubs are very susceptible to
pneumonia so the mothers know so well
not to expose their cubbies to the rain
and I'm very happy that you all wish me
good luck but these cuts will show and
why not they have no reason not to show
up and what you left is now a part of
the spotlight just to switch off the car
and just listen for any calls from the
Lions now Trish is definitely following
hard
so they've been quite mobile
Oh guys that was amazing so what you
heard there was a combination of the
roars with The Barking of the nearby
antelope can start yet him
Wow that's sour enough that floor and
that's not even a full wall that's
basically them trying to contact the
other liens that are around oh where you
going to those antelope ever really seen
you let's move a little bit forward it's
as exciting a phenom oh you've done a
bit of scent marking in front of us but
why this is awesome is that now is when
they're most active
and animals I mean lions are meeting
will often share kill together even
though it's just three of them they
might decide to take some take down
something together [ __ ] he's he's going
he's sent barking Fleming grimacing
smelling where the females had sent
marking so it's all very exciting this
is really cool I've wanted to be with
the Lions for such a long time and
finally they are yeah well anyway it
seems that Tristan has finally caught up
with Tandy and Tandy is in a fabulous
position so let's go over her to him and
her well as you can see unfortunately by
the time we caught up with her she had
already got up into the tree with her
little Nala lamb that she's
unfortunately managed to kill now I say
unfortunately because it's always sad
when a little animal is killed but she's
safely got it up in the tree because I
in has arrived as she got up in there we
started to see hyenas coming in and so I
haven't ID'd which hyenas are around
they've kind of gone the other side of
the tree and you can see it's a bit
dense and a bit thick so we're gonna
have to try and work out where we gonna
kind of situate ourselves but HIPAA
kippa kippa cat we managed to find the
Queen I don't think there's gonna last
long she should still be here tomorrow
morning but at least we managed to catch
up with this evening and we can really
get kind of a good look at what's going
on with Tandy she does look quite round
and she hasn't actually started to feed
on this lamb at all yet unfortunate is
that time away I need to say goodbye to
all of you and so it's been an absolute
pleasure this afternoon hopefully you've
enjoyed the myriad of animals that we've
had and hopefully we will see you
joining us in half an hour for the s ABC
TV show but from all of us it's been an
absolute pleasure
we'll see you just now oh I'll see you
tomorrow morning for the sunrise Safari
[Music]